and there's a friend of mine who says
like starting companies like staring at
the abyss and eating glass and there's
some truth to that there were times when
something is important enough you
believe it enough that you do it in
spite of fear I'm just in general
critical thinking is good what a sore
get a mentor what's not believe nation
eight seven I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so today let's
learn from one of the best Elon Musk and
five of his most life-changing pieces of
advice mentor me Elon also if you want
to know what Elon Musk and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
length of join is in the description
below there are just times when
something is important enough you
believe it enough but you do you do it
in spite of fear
[Music]
okay let's hit get off with rule number
one have a high pain threshold one does
have to be focused on the short term and
money coming in when creating company
because otherwise the company will die
so that I think that a lot of times
people think like creating company is
gonna be fun I would say it's not it's
really not that fun I mean there are
periods of fun and there are periods of
where to where she's awful and
particularly if you CEO of the company
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in the company
there's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right so you
only spend on things on your time on
things that are going wrong and and
there are things that are going wrong
that other people can't can't take care
of so you're like the worst you have a
filter for the crappers problems in the
company the most pernicious and painful
problem so I wouldn't say it's it's it I
think you have to feel quite compelled
to do it and have a fairly high pain
threshold and there's a friend of mine
who says like starting companies like
staring at the abyss and eating glass
and there's some truth to that we're
starting to the best part is that you're
gonna be constantly facing the
extermination of the company because
most startups fail yeah it's like 90
percent ugly 99% of startzville so I so
you that that's the staring into the
abyss part you can't stir constantly
saying okay let's if I don't get this
right the company will die should be
quite rightful quite stressful and and
then the eating glass part is you've got
you've got to do you've got to do the
problems you're gonna sell you're gonna
work on the problems that the company
needs you to work on not the problems
you want to work on and so that the
that's you and I've working on problems
that that if you really wish you weren't
working on okay so that's the eating
grass part then that goes on for a long
time so how do you keep your focus on
the big picture when you're constantly
faced with we could be out of business
in a month
well it's just a very small percentage
of mental energies on the on the big
picture like you know you know where you
generally heading for and and the
fascial path is gonna be some sort of
zig zag thing in that direction and try
not to deviate too far from the path
that that you want to be on but you're
gonna have to do that some degree but I
don't want to I don't want to diminish
the I mean I think the product the
profit motive is it is a is a good one
if the rules of an industry are properly
set up so there's only fundamentally
wrong with profit in fact profit just
means that people are paying you more
for whatever you're doing then you're
spending to create it that's a good
thing and if you're not if that's not
the case then you'll be out of business
and rightfully so sure you're not adding
enough value rule number two don't let
failure stop you what was your biggest
failure and how did I change you to
really think hard about that failure
there's your answer
yeah well there's a ton of failures
along the way that's for sure
like I said as a support for SpaceX the
first three launches failed and we were
just barely able to scrape together
enough parts and money to do the fourth
launch that both launch had failed we
would have been dead so multiple
failures along the way I tried very hard
to get the right expertise in for for
SpaceX I tried hard to find a great
chief engineer for the rocket but it but
the good chief engineers wouldn't join
and the bad ones well there's no no
point hiring him
so I ended up a chief engineer at the
rocket so if I could have found somebody
better then we would have maybe had less
than three failures rule number three
work super hard on your vision
I think certainly being focused on
something that you're confident will
have high value to someone else and just
being really rigorous in making that
assessment
because people are attend tend to
natural human tendency is wishful
thinking so a challenge for
entrepreneurs is to say well what's the
difference between really believing in
your ideals and sticking sticking to
them versus pursuing some unrealistic
dream that doesn't actually have merit
and it's it's that is it that is a
really difficult thing to to tell you
can you tell the difference between
those two things I know so you need to
be sort of very rigorous in in your self
self analysis I think certainly
extremely tenacious and and then just
work like hell I mean you just have to
put in you know 80 hour 80 100 hour
weeks every week and then matter like
that but all those things improve the
odds of success okay I mean if other
people are putting in 40 hour work weeks
and you're putting in 100 hour work
weeks then even if you're doing the same
thing you know that in in one year you
will achieve what that she you you will
achieve in four months what it takes
them a year to achieve when my brother
and I was studying our first company
instead of getting an apartment we just
rented us a small office and we slept on
the couch and we showered at the YMCA
and we're so hot up we had just one
computer so the the website was up
during the day and I was coding at night
seven days a week all the time
and I sort of briefly had a gopher in
that period and in order to be with me
she have to sleep in the office so I
work hard like and it mean every waking
hour that's that's the the thing I would
I would say if you're particularly if
you're starting a company and I mean if
you do simple math to say like okay if
somebody else is working 50 hours when
you're working 100 you'll get twice as
done as much done in the course of a
year as the other company rule number
four act despite fear you are unusually
fearless and willing to go in the face
of other people telling you something
that's crazy and I
a lot of pretty crazy people you still
stand out where does that come from or
how do you think about making a decision
when everyone tells you this is a crazy
idea where do you get the internal
strength to do that well first of all
I'd say I actually think I feel feel
fair quite strongly so it's not as
though I just have the absence of fear
I've I feel it quite strongly but there
were times when something is important
enough you believe it enough that you do
you do it in spite of fear so speaking
of important things like people
shouldn't think III I should if you
should think well I feel fear about this
and therefore I shouldn't do it it's
normal to be to feel fear like you'd
have to do something mentally wrong you
shouldn't feel fair so you just feel it
and let the importance of it drive you
to do it anyway yeah you know actually
we're something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree if you just think
it's just accept the probabilities then
that diminishes fear so we're starting
SpaceX I thought the odds of success
were less than 10% and I just accepted
that actually probably I would just lose
lose everything but that maybe would
make some progress if we could just move
the ball forward even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward so that were still do some good
yeah same with Tesla I thought your odds
of a car company succeeding were
extremely low and rule number five the
last time before a very special bonus
clip is create a great team you need a
team around you to deliver a lot of idea
how do you choose your team be somewhat
well I suppose honestly that it tends to
be gut feel more than anything else so
when I interview somebody the might of
your question is always the same it's
just I said tell me the
your life and and the decisions that you
made a long way and why you made them
and then if and it and also tell me
about some of the most difficult
problems you worked on and how you
solved them and that that question I
think is very important because the
people that really solve the problem
they know exactly how they solved it
they know the little details and the
people that pretend it to solve a
problem they can maybe go one level and
then they get stuck
advice I forgot well I think the you
know the physics training is a very good
training where it's a good framework for
reasoning we you're trained to think
about first principles and reason from
there and that means blending things
down to the most fundamental truths and
then connecting those truths in a way to
try to understand how reality is because
you know physics has this problem where
they're trying to figure out things that
are totally counterintuitive and so they
had to have a framework for forgetting
they're like quantum mechanics is
incredibly counterintuitive but it's
true and so you had so the physics
developed a framework for figuring out
things that aren't obvious and that's
why I think it's it's what it's it's a
lot of advice but it's it's it's the
right framework and then just in general
critical thinking is good you know
examining whether you have the correct
axioms are the most applicable axioms
does the logic necessarily connect and
then what are the what are the range of
probable outcomes outcomes are usually
not deterministic there and they're
there a range and so you want to figure
out what those probabilities are and
make sure ideally that you or the house
you know it's fine to take spot it's
fine to it's fine to gamble as long as
you're the house yeah
and you know and it's up so that is is
to listen to critical feedback which we
alluded to earlier voice oolitic solicit
critical feedback particularly from
friends because generally they will be
thinking it but they want to tell you
ways your standard Apple at the core is
core values
is that we believe that people your
passion can change the way people not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean
if you want more ilan check out the
video I made on how to be the next Elon
Musk the link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
a challenge for entrepreneurs is to say
well what's the difference between
really believing in new ideals and
sticking sticking to them
[Music]